four years ago yesterday there was a
shooting at my younger sister Jenny's
high school sagus high school in Santa
Clarita California Jenny was lucky
enough to see kids running when she was
about to be dropped off by her carpool
so she stayed safe but all of her
friends were placed on lockdown kids
I've watched grow up and have known for
as long as I can
remember in the hours that follow
parents waited at my City Central Park
to reunite with their kids as students
were released building by building
escorted by police and SWAT teams to the
park 3 days later there was a vigil at
that same Central Park to honor Gracie
melberger and Dominic Blackwell whose
parents laid them to rest at the tender
ages of 15 and
14 it was the largest gathering in my
City's history despite the divisions in
my hometown we stood at peace with one
another that night yearning for a better
future this very American Tragedy that
we have had to witness time and time
again speaks to a larger issue about
democracy like many people in the face
of tragedy I wanted to do something and
to do something to truly participate in
democracy we have to acknowledge that
Injustice is cyclical and that any fight
of a neighbor is the fight of our own
but how do we wherever we may be with
whatever tools we have fight that fight
I've realized over the course of growing
up that what we largely consider to be
participating in democracy is honestly
kind of narrow and unimaginative we're
taught that we can vote and run for
office which are both important but what
about those of us who can't because of
our age our immigration status our class
not to mention the countless others
facing disenfranchised through voter
suppression the truth is any of us of
any age living in some semblance of a
democracy or striving towards it possess
the tools to have a voice in our
governments and communities it's just a
matter of learning how to have agency
with those tools for me that's been
coding and social media it's
unconventional but I found the most
success in having an influence by using
whatever is in front of me really tuning
in to my networks and communities
meeting people where they're at and
centering joy and fun wherever I can and
it works let me explain in the case of
this school shooting the parents of
Gracie milberger and Dominic Blackwell
began a push to have the two of them
memorialized at the entrance of our
Central Park to me and much of my
community this Memorial was a no-brainer
to others it was grandiose and highly
inappropriate that's a direct quote by
the way and a number of local officials
agreed with them but that cannot and
should not nullify the needs and the
wants of the Greater Community so Gracie
and Dominic's parents determined to
properly memorialize their children
created a petition and organized efforts
to push our city council to approve the
memorial the petition got over 10,000
signatures and people emailed the city
in masses eventually they approved and
we all thought we were done
but as it turns out the land that
Central Park is on is owned by the Santa
Clarita waterboard so they had the final
say and a Committee created to advise on
that decision penned a seven-page paper
on why they should actually reject the
memorial and we didn't even know about
this or know this was still up for
debate until the day they were supposed
to vote on it I was so unbelievably
angry how is it that the community can
come together organize and finally get a
win just for it to be rendered fruitless
by a vocal minority with fancy
titles I wasn't having it but I still
felt powerless I wasn't on the committee
I wasn't an elected official I couldn't
even tell you what a water board did but
like I said I had these two sources of
power coding and social media you may be
thinking girl like okay but but follow
me here follow me here I learned to code
when I was 15 at a code with clossy
summer program where I learned that I
could apply that skill to anything and
everything and on the content side of
things I got bored during the pandemic
and loved giving my unsolicited opinion
and yelling on the internet so I got a
pretty sizable following on Tik Tok and
joined the organization genz for Change
and posting content to mobilize My
Generation to vote in the 2020 election
so I knew that with these two Powers I
held I could do something I could make
something real in the three or so hours
I had so I got to work I found an email
address where people could send public
comments on agenda items and coded a
tool where people could just put in
their name affiliation anything else
they wanted to send and a randomly
generated email would be created all
they had to do was push send I finished
it like 15 minutes before the deadline
it was one of the ugliest websites I had
ever
made I posted it to Instagram Twitter
Tik Tok I had around ,000 followers at
the time I sent it to my family my
sister sent it to her friends who sent
to their friends and then I held my
breath a few hours later the waterboard
voted 9 to3 to approve the memorial and
I felt at
ease it wasn't until a few months later
though that I learned that out of the
the 63 comments submitted 56 the vast
majority were sent using the tool that I
had
coded which is so insane because there
was so little time people were able to
use it in the first place this success
was a testament to the fact that so
often people want to speak out they want
to do something but don't know how or
get discouraged in the face of
bureaucracy making it a little bit
easier for folks needs to be a core
value for all of us in another instance
Virginia governor Glenn yunan created a
tip line to report critical race Theory
being taught in schools I had a problem
with that so I wanted there to be an
easy fun Community oriented way to get
this tip line taken down as soon as
possible so I coded a tool that allowed
people to send song lyrics and lines
from the be movie to the tip line
essentially it takes the name of a real
school School a real City in Virginia
and spits out a very ridiculous report
for example I have reason to believe
Thomas Jefferson High School is teaching
race I overheard a teacher saying shotty
had them Apple Bottom
Jeans yeah it's silly it's goofy it's
just as unserious as the creation of a
teach reporting tip line itself which is
exactly what draws people to this kind
of action democracy is just more fun and
inviting when you take it into your own
hands after I finished the website I
sent it to my friends at jenz for change
we all posted videos thousands of emails
were sent from every state in the
country and virtually every continent
and we had emails bouncing within 48
Hours months later the tip line was
quietly officially shut down didn't even
last a year because of the skills of a
few the platforms of many and the will
will of hundreds of thousands of
meddling kids unified in our intolerance
of Injustice we were far more powerful
than a couple people in official
positions of power now I'm not asking
y'all to drop everything and learn how
to code even though I definitely think
you
should coding is part of my power right
but Power manifests differently to
different people if you have a pen write
something if you have an instrument play
something if you have the anger of a
thousand sons and disposable income open
your
purse and if you have social media and a
smartphone I know that y'all do so don't
try me tell a story and let it spread
like wildfire and while it's true that a
subset of people use their skills for
hateful nefarious less than Democratic
purposes the sheer existence of this
subset requires that we think of more
Innovative and creative ways to ensure
that the voices of the masses are
genuinely heard and accounted for now
every time I'm home and I walk by
Central Park and see the new signage I'm
reminded of the power our anguish our
joy our stories and our Unity holds we
were able to change my community forever
and for the better all by causing a
ruckus on the internet the stability of
democracy International
requires that we use whatever skills and
resources we have to combat hate bring
movements to life and Stand United in
solidarity with one another on every
corner of the globe Justice can't wait
so take what's in front of you get
really creative and cause a
ruckus